on wednesday
netflix dropped black pink light up the
sky
a documentary about the south korean
girl group black pink
now we're breaking down the 11 must-see
moments with the global superstars
so nice to hear i mean that's kind of
what we live for the whole doc hits a
high note with blackpink's performance
at coachella in 2019
[Music]
if anything it's like stressful like
sometimes if something's not working or
if i'm not doing my best performance it
can be stressful
that performance made them the first
korean girl group to play at the annual
desert music festival
it's definitely a moment that we'll
never forget
it was one of this important steps that
we
took last year to make us into a better
artist and a better selves we're really
really thankful
for the opportunity that we had to go on
and perform at coachella and still we're
so happy about it it's a life-changing
moment
the doc shows the singers rehearsing for
the gig and reveals how they spent the
moments backstage
before show
[Music]
the documentary also takes a close look
at the ultra competitive k-pop industry
where groups are assembled by veteran
talent spotters
and put through an intense training
regimen
k-pop k-pop is taking the us by storm
k-pop has become a worldwide cultural
phenomenon we're not
allowed to drink or smoke or get a
tattoo
yeah their practice schedule was so
intense they were only allowed
one day off every two weeks
the ladies of black pink also recall
missing out on typical teenage stuff
while they were trying to launch their
careers
a lot of people make lots of memories as
like a high school
student but i never had that
and missing their families in australia
i i dropped out of school i had never
even imagined myself living apart from
my family i hadn't even like slept
more than two weeks out of home it was a
really hard time
i'm gonna cry they also open up about
the pressure to succeed
home get our
and experiencing body image issues
the group gets super vulnerable in the
dock and when eti caught up with black
pink back in september
they revealed why now was the right time
to share a more raw side of themselves
with their fans
who are lovingly called blinks in the
beginning
of our debut and stuff we were we wanted
to be
very sure about the contents that we put
out
and make sure to not let anyone see our
flaws maybe
but i think we've come
to a point where we kind of laid back
and kind of share
the unfiltered real versions of us to
the world
ready to just be vulnerable and kind of
just be like this is how we started
and this is why and how we got here
kind of story yeah yeah it was about
time
yeah that they get stuff like that oh
and speaking of their debut
they open up about their chart-topping
debut single whistle
is
jumped up into our room and they reveal
why that song
almost didn't make the cut and we almost
didn't come out with
whistle for our debut song but like
because too many people thought it was
risky
yeah but last minute we were like it has
to be in the end
one thing is crystal clear the ladies of
blackpink
our family
so is basically what you called her
older a sister like it's she's not she's
she's on me it's like family